to mrs emma cook the executive director
of ema
mrs cook please thank you very much mrs
heiner
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
thank you for joining us again for this
press briefing
first of all i want to start by stating
that our
safety committee the pharmacovigilance
and risk assessment committee of the
european medicines agency has confirmed
that the benefits of the astrazeneca
vaccine
in preventing covert 19 overall
outweigh the risks of side effects
covet 19 is a very serious disease
with high hospitalization and death
rates and every day
cobot is still causing thousands of
deaths across the
eu this vaccine has proven to be highly
effective
it prevents severe disease and
hospitalization and it is saving lives
vaccination is extremely important in
helping us
in the fight against covet 19 and we
need to use the vaccines we have
to protect us from the devastating
effects
the prague after a very in-depth
analysis
has concluded that the reported cases of
unusual
blood clotting following vaccination
with the astrazeneca vaccine
should be listed as possible side
effects of the vaccine
as we communicated last week we convened
an ad hoc
expert group composed of experts from a
range of medical specialities including
hematologists
neurologists epidemiologists and
virologists
based on the current available evidence
specific risk factors such as age
gender or previous medical history of
of clotting disorders have not been able
to be confirmed
as the rarest events are seen in all
ages
and in men and women a plausible
explanation for these rare side events
is that is an immune response to the
vaccine
leading to a condition similar to one
seen
sometimes in patients treated with
heparin it's called heparin-induced
thrombocytopenia
and dr strauss will give us more details
from the assessments
ema is working very closely with the
national competence authorities in all
the eu member states
and the company to make sure that these
risks are proactively communicated
to health care professionals it's
important
that both vaccinated people and health
care professionals are aware of the
signs and symptoms
of these unusual blood clotting
disorders so that they can be spotted
quickly to minimize any possible risks
we will continue to monitor the
scientific
evidence available on both effectiveness
and safety of
all the authorized covet 19 vaccines and
we will issue
further recommendations if necessary on
the grounds of science and robust
evidence